now we've got something very very
important in either one to see a very
special panini
so they put something together for him
panini don't be a meanie
[Music]
I'm sorry we didn't so
yeah finally I can wrestle pretty don't
be a meanie amazing yeah we're going to
show you one
[Music]
[Music]
right my man you ready yes let's get
this thing going
that was funny by the pop-up inning so
we can do with the pound body okay which
is amazing ancient but it's super soft
delicious and I would put that okay we
got the power button okay inside here so
using my legs spread that on there look
spread it victim across in fact your
cost yeah all over all over yellow right
to our heartfelt fragrance on there I
made it right from there would take some
Asami okay
now I said from there
trim and then from there okay such a
cabbage we go a bit slow in that
do
and there's a spicy kimchi
that's what I got that thing excellent
so far so good in that literally makes
us all cascading down this chute down by
then we want a little bit on the other
side we got the top the bottom
nice sign up press two minutes
right why is that cooking we're going to
show you something that develop
especially
two minutes all right we gotta see these
pieces chop it up
that's a pretty bow Samir was amazing
yeah I say as well and you know
sometimes the weather so [ __ ] that the
capsule that way though man I mean let
me do it to actually like Stevie yeah
you ready yeah don't bail please let's
let let's close up with a on the reveal
because this is this is this is talking
to a guy please don't my panini yes
that is Jules man yo shut yours
wait-wait-wait-wait over get out of the
way first
yeah
there we go
[Music]